well earlier we heard that texas senator
ted cruz the call for more armed police
officers to be stationed at schools
across the united states joining me now
someone who agrees with that
conservative radio host ben ferguson ben
you and i
have had a lot of fiery debates over the
years about gun control so i don't want
to have one of those with you because i
think i don't think they ever really
achieved very much and then when i watch
social media today everyone on all sides
of this debate blowing up uh emotionally
raging on both sides ever more
entrenched
what
is try and get to a place
where we can at least agree some things
and i just wonder you know you're a guy
from texas you're a father
when you heard about this
you're a gun owner and you support the
second amendment and i fully respect
that but when you heard about this
tragedy what was your sort of gut
feeling about this
i i think first it was
why in america do we not protect our
children our most vulnerable and most
valuable
by making sure that there's law
enforcement at every public school we
protect our president we protect our
senators we protect our governors we
protect our money at our banks we
protect the jewelry at the jewelry store
with armed guards guards but we don't
protect our children with iron guards we
can obviously afford it america just
said ben says
there was an armed guard at the school
and he challenged he challenged the
shooter before he got in and he got shot
he got shot and disabled so you have
there was an armed guard there but and
there wasn't there was in the buffalo
system let me finish yeah but i mean you
do you know that there was an armed
guard
let me
let me let me finish
you you had two different police
officers that were actually shot by this
individual yesterday and you had border
patrol agents that responded but you had
an open door to that school and if you
have security measures at a school the
way that many private schools do them in
the country they make sure that those
schools are locked and that someone
can't just randomly come in from the
outside
and that's part of the problem we don't
have enough police officers who
understand the lockdowns of a school to
protect the children from outside
individuals trying to get in and my
point is this we are supposed to be a
wealthy nation just like your your
country is as well we just spent 40
billion dollars to ukraine uh the people
that by the way are yelling about guns
right now the same people demanding we
send more guns to ukraine which i think
is very odd but we have to do a better
job of finding a consensus here and
saying you know you mentioned earlier
that the and he said some interesting
things uh the coach of golden state a
couple years ago he came out in a very
fiery comment saying that he did not
want to have armed guards at schools and
then today he comes out with this very
fiery statement there's got to be some
compromise where parents can say okay we
all agree that our children are valuable
and we need to make sure that we have
mechanisms and we have the a way that we
do business every day at these schools
to protect these children the same way
we have protocols around presidential
leaders i would agree with you right i
don't think there's any option other
than to protect schools more given this
appalling tragedy and given what
happened at sandy hook and given the
hundreds of school shootings since sandy
hook uh there's got to be more security
but just for the record there was an
armed police guard at this school it's
emerged tonight and there was an armed
guard and there was
there was an armed guard at the
supermarket in buffalo so armed guards
alone
are actually not that effective it turns
out when you're facing a guy with full
body armor with a semi-automatic rival
who has the ability and advantage of
surprise it's very hard for one armed
guard so what do you do then do you then
have a number of arms at every school do
you have a whole sort of small army did
you turn the schools into militarized
bases what do you do
again this is where i have to disagree
with you my father's in law enforcement
and what do you do when you have one
police officer and you have a dangerous
situation you immediately call for what
backup and then when you are around
someone that's a world leader what do
you see you don't see one secret service
agent or one police officer when there
are people that you could know could
attack you have more than one and that's
what we have messed up in this country
we are not valuing the lives of our
children to the point where we should
say if you have a large campus and you
listen to the experts that talk about
how quickly a police officer can get
from one side of the campus the other
they all tell you the same thing you do
need multiple armed guards because it
takes too long
for somebody to get from one side of the
school the other doesn't mean it's
militarized all right look so you're
talking about multiple armed guards
let's come to the other issue of the age
that people are legally allowed to get
these high-powered semi-automatic rifles
i don't understand how it can be illegal
to get a beer until you're 21
in most states in america but it's
perfectly legal to buy a semi-automatic
rifle or why it's you can't get a kinder
surprise chocolate egg anywhere in
america because you may choke on my
little toy but you can buy
hand guns i don't understand
that can you explain the logic behind
that
sure i think what one of the problems
you have in this country uh and i think
you have around the world with lawmakers
is they're consistently inconsistent uh
with actually doing things that make
sense is it weird that you can buy a gun
at 18 but you can't buy a beer until
you're 21 of course it is is it weird
that you can go serve your country and
we'll train you how to become a killer
of terrorists around the world but you
can't drink a beer when you come home
from that trip that is insanity the fact
of the matter is though it's not an age
issue in this country right now as much
as we want to obsess over it it's a lack
of parenting issue in this country that
we have look at what we see consistently
look at the man that we're talking about
right now he just turned 18. there were
massive warning signs that this person
was clearly mentally troubled he came to
an event and he had slashed his own
cheeks and said it was fun and he wanted
to feel the pain he had talked about
committing heinous crimes and violence
look at what happened in buffalo we know
the shooter there threatened to kill
people at his school we have the warning
signs you have a parent and grandmother
who had called the police on this
individual multiple times now think
about that from a parent but you as a
parent protect your children
i agree but all your painting is an even
more inexplicable picture as to why
these kids who are clearly mentally ill
you have to be mentally ill to do what
they do mentally ill are able to just
wander into any gun stool perfectly
legally and buy semi-automatic rifles
but they can't get a beer uh look i've
got to leave it there
but it's a sad day
is it gonna change if they're at 21
probably not
that's
an arbitrary age is not going to fix
this if we want to fix this problem we
need to number one protect the schools
we should have bipartisan support on
that and two we need to make sure that
when law enforcement is called to
someone's house from a parent begging
for help for a child that clearly has
having massive problems that we have
mechanisms to stop them from actually
doing this yeah i think you need all of
that and then you need to stop deranged
young people being able to legally get
assault rifles and send me send me
automatic rifles anyway ben we've got to
leave you there you know i want to have
a constructive ongoing dialogue about
this because it can't go on america
can't just keep waking up to these
tragedies it's it's just heartbreaking
for everybody you got another whole
series of families now lives completely
destroyed so at least i'm sure we can
agree this cannot go on like it is doing
nothing cannot be the sensible humane
option so we've got to keep talking
we've got to find points of consensus i
don't think shouting on either side ever
gets anywhere with these debates so
let's you know keep talking come back
again let's discuss it and let's see if
we can get to points of consensus and
try and help things
good to talk to you totally agree thank
you